current education system what do you
think about the current education system
that we have that's a really broad
question well you said you like opinions
so go for it give us a strong opinion on
things I don't know anything about you
want to talk about like colleges you
don't talk about like 12. you think go
go through both you know yesterday Kyle
had a lot of strong opinions on you know
we should forgive all the college debt
all that stuff but I'm talking more the
format like our educational system K
through 12 and he can go into college as
well I read a quote a long time ago uh I
don't remember who it was from but so
many the quote that I read was that if
you were to pull somebody out of the
18th century and you would have
transport them into today the only thing
they would recognize would be the
schools that like we have a way of
educating people we've done it for like
hundreds of years and we actually it's
completely false okay well we didn't
have schools in the 1700s nobody got
educated anywhere we didn't have schools
in the 1700s we didn't have schools
they would recognize the schools there
were no schools in England or whatever
like it must have been some sort of
colleges but not schools okay colleges
am I sorry but not school so they
wouldn't recognize the school system
okay can we what is our terms does
college not kind of school or okay when
you say schools you mean k through 12.
we call College colleges okay well I
don't mean that but maybe for the
purpose of this conversation that we can
mean that okay college is a separate
thing from school
um I feel like there are a couple of if
we're talking about like classes I feel
like there are a few basic classes that
like every student should be required to
take that we don't
um so things like a basic home at class
I think a basic Psych in a basic
philosophy course I think would be
really important
um like just a couple of the things that
help us like exist in the world and like
file our taxes and be like a little bit
critical of like the things we watch
um and then I know that largely speaking
I know we've got troubles in schools
that throw more money at least in some
places doesn't seem to help but I think
schools are hard because sometimes
that's like the last stop of like a
whole bunch of problems prior to that
right if you've got a kid coming from
like a single parent family who's not
getting much sleep whose household is in
like a really you know [ __ ] up area
um you know at that point how much can
particular like K-12 School actually do
for the child I'm not entirely sure
past that if we're talking about
colleges
um I I think colleges are pretty okay in
the United States we have our really
good schools people all around the world
come to get educated in
um I think that people opt too much for
out-of-state schools you've got people
talking about I've got you know 200 000
in debt and it's like okay cool are you
a doctor and they're like no I'm like a
mechanical engineer but I did like seven
years of like out of state you know plus
tuition and board and everything and
it's like why the [ __ ] did you do that
um but yeah I think largely speaking I
think that like the college stuff is
okay I'm not a big fan of student loan
forgiveness
um why not
uh I I okay I coming from Like A Working
Poor background before I got into
streaming I feel like the middle class
asked for a lot of tax breaks sometimes
when I look at like really working poor
people I'm like damn these people are
[ __ ] okay and you want to have your
student loan debt forgiven when you're
gonna go on to become some of the like
the top tier earners in all of society I
think if you look at the I know they're
very interesting yeah the cost of
education has grown but the average
amount of time to pay back a degree
based on getting a degree I think is
about the same as it always has been 20
years
um to pay back your debt that's the
average I think I thought it was 15 but
it might be 28 I guess anyway maybe for
you know yeah but go getters like you
you can do it in 15 but on average I
think it's 19 20 years maybe yeah
um but the the the people that earn
college degrees go on to become the
highest earners in society so if we're
going to Target stimulus towards any
part of like the economy I'd rather go
towards people that are like working
poor and not towards people that are
like Engineers that just want to get rid
of like a 500 600 a month like student
loan debt pay you're saying targeting
stimulus or anything like what we talk
about rather than spend the money to pay
off people's debt that that they chose
to incur themselves in order to get
ahead in this life that they're going to
be rewarded for well there are limits to
it by the way the whole Biden ten
thousand dollar you know student loan
didn't pass correct this was something
it didn't happen
I think it's in this it's stalled and
the Supreme Court I want to say I think
it's in the new one is nobody got the
ten thousand dollars or twenty thousand
dollars did they open and I know people
were putting in applications I don't
know if anybody's gotten it yet don't
get me started on these sites they're
crashing on the websites um but the the
but there were limitations I think if
you made over 150 000 a year you did not
qualify and then people with Pell Grants
were qualified for up to twenty thousand
if you were gonna do it I think it was
probably the best way to do it and it's
a maybe a good way to get young people
like they don't otherwise you even point
this out like uh I'll say this college
prep and career Readiness is a Ponzi
scheme they got your kid for 12 years
they've already convinced you and they
have they've got 12 years to convince
the kid you need to go to college
because if you don't go to college
you're screwed and so you got to go to
college and what is that that's that's
just you got to pay a lot of money to a
school somewhere so that you have a
college degree and it's they're in
nowhere in school do they say why you
have to go to college it's just so that
you can earn the money but but it's it's
not like let's make a plan for you if
you go to this school it will cost you
eighty thousand dollars total over four
years and then you have this potential
of this earning no you can go for basket
weaving and get two hundred thousand
dollars in debt or whatever and you
completely unemployable and so my point
is the whole thing is at this point it's
just a Ponzi scheme it might be based on
data that came from 50 years ago but at
this point you know we got to wake up
and smell the coffee kids don't
necessarily have to go to college and
you you went to school you graduated no
I failed okay well I had to work too
much yeah right yeah so so you're a
Dropout wait Zuckerberg not
not everybody can do what I do though I
got no but Zuckerberg's a Dropout Gates
is a drop oh no no no no no no no no no
no no hold on hold on dropped out
Harvard people like Bill Gates and
Zuckerberg quit school because they were
too busy working on projects if you're a
guy that's failing like remedial algebra
and you quit school you're not gonna
become the next kitten but bear with me
what I'm saying is you do not have to
have a college degree to succeed in life
and so setting up a child and saying you
have to have a college degree in order
to succeed is a false Paradigm it's just
false there are a lot of people who
succeed in fact most of my friends I
don't know did you did you graduate okay
most of my friends who are entrepreneurs
who are self-starters who are successful
in life did not go to college and did
not graduate or did go to college for a
short term and figured it out and didn't
graduate and so my point is it's a Ponzi
scheme they're all in debt and now
they're all saying hey government bail
me I think I think you're doing a
disservice to college hear me out
um because there's parts of what you're
saying that I agree with and there's
parts of the of what you're saying that
I I just think is not not the best
portrayal only other person I've ever
met is actually to defend college on a
show yeah because there's Different
Strokes for different folks
um when you say that college is a Ponzi
scheme it it depends on the this is why
I think the decisions you're making when
you're 17 and 18 are the most important
decisions in your life like where am I
going to school you really have to do
the ROI on College because it's been
proven that a high school completely
unprepared to make those decisions
totally agree youth has wasted on the
young that's true but it's been proven
that if you look at the math that if a
high school degree you'll earn a million
dollars over your lifetime a million
two million exactly two million dollars
which you what you will earn on a
college degree okay and then as you get
a PhD or a master's you can earn
lifetime earnings on average three four
five million right now for every
Bill Gates that drops out Mark
Zuckerberg that drops out or pbd that is
to go to college there's hundreds and
thousands of people that are just
average people so that's why I totally
agree with you on this here's the
problem that that I think is lacking in
America is there's a need for technical
schools right these vocational schools
but the problem is if you're going to go
to high school right you're going to go
k through 12 and you're taking all these
classes algebra biology math this and
they say hey by the way after high
school you should go become a plumber
what 18 year old kid is gonna be like
I've been in school this whole time and
now you want me to go back to being a
plumber and what they don't understand
is some plumbers will make 100 Grand a
year and you might only make 40 Grand a
year maybe for your liberal arts degree
New York well okay but so you're making
my point for me no but the point is this
is that that no very few people are
going to go through school for 18 years
or 12 years and then be like all right
let me go be a plumber or a sewage guy
or a garbage man but even though the ROI
on that that is greater than that's true
sometimes a college degree because of
the whole college prep and career
Readiness Ponzi scheme that's the only
reason why is it a Ponzi scheme if you
get it exactly you get because because
it's like a pyramid scheme it's like you
pay in on the bottom and then as as more
people pay in you will get more money on
the outcome yeah but you don't accept
that for a lot of people they don't get
it
indoctrination of that you have to go to
the some out of state school and spend
50 Grand a year if you're okay with
going to community college and taking
basic classes and your way that's the
thing is you can get out of you can get
out of it that's not a Ponzi scheme a
Ponzi scheme relies for you to get the
money at the top from new people coming
in at the point that's right but when
you if you go and get a degree in
nuclear engineering you're not getting
money from school you go out in the job
market you get paid in the job market
that's not a Ponzi scheme well it is
because when the government comes in and
bails out everybody's student loans and
all of that then it's all it's all of a
piece well okay the whole feeder thing
yeah but that doesn't have anything two
if School how many Ponzi schemes could
you kill immediately and like every
single person that is like graduated
would still be making money that's not a
fancy scheme but okay so my my point is
that it's a setup okay because there
there are plenty of of kids who really
shouldn't be going to college they're
much better served not going to college
and there are plenty of kids in college
who are being disserved by being taught
things that simply aren't true about
themselves and about life in general
that's a different story so for me I
think what what you guys are saying is
everybody here has a point and everybody
here is making a good counter argument
to the other person this is what I would
say to say all of it like I want doctors
to go to college like stem is I don't
know I don't I don't think you're saying
that I think stem you need to go to
school for stem I'm not going to have
somebody working my dad's heart that's
never gone to school and hasn't gone and
done you know additional things you need
to be a heart surgeon yeah I I and I'm
not saying that nobody should go to
college right you're saying what I'm
saying is that the the rule shouldn't be
sure simply applied I think the part I
have a challenge with is the following
area the part I have a challenge with is
the fact that you know for every one
conservative Professor there's 13
liberal that's the problem for every
like for example the one thing you got
to give so much credit to the left is
they understood if you want to control
the way people think go control
universities okay yeah you got to do
that but by the way Republicans were
lazy on it that's true they have one
school which is what Hillsdale and maybe
you got a couple other Christian schools
that you got you know Bible schools that
you got what else do the Republic even
even Duke nowadays is what it's on the
left yeah Duke is not the Duke of 30
years ago yeah Harvard so so with the
Republicans rather than taking the money
that they had in creating some real
universities they just said no I'm gonna
go out there and just do my business
stuff that's what I'm going to be doing
I'm not going to go out you need a pen
yeah can you give give them a pen if you
don't mind yeah thank you so I think
that part is a mistake of the right you
know like right now the left is losing
their minds because Elon Musk by Twitter
why because they've been controlling
media for how long now God knows how
long that's strategically a good move on
them so Elon comes in he starts exposing
everything and I'm like yeah Twitter
files don't even talk about it on
mainstream media they're scared shitless
that's how you compete you compete that
way I I we've lost the competition
because they've now they've they've
indoctrinated all of the teachers K-12
so our schools are gone that's a lazy
side of Republicans do you think but it
doesn't matter because it's the kids now
that are I don't disagree with you I
don't disagree with you and you think
that we we have us we have a chance to
fight for the Second Amendment the
Second Amendment is gone because all of
the kids today disagree that are going
to uh to zero tolerance schools are
learning that guns are bad
yeah full stop but okay so then the
question for me becomes if if as a
capitalist and a and a person myself
that I'm fiscally conservative as a
capitalist I like to say what are you
doing about it pat that's my Mo in my
family life what am I doing about it
okay perfect if that's what Republicans
stand for what are you doing about a
personal responsibility then damn it
Republicans take some personal
responsibility and ask yourself how many
universities have you started how many
schools have you started how much time
have you put into it why don't you take
your top 40 50 richest billionaire
Republicans and say set aside you really
want to do this I'm going to give 100 of
my money away to what [ __ ] Charities
stop spending your why aren't you
sending your money to these institutions
it's just because you graduated because
they're not United and they're lazy get
together and say Here's 50 billion
dollars over the next 20 years to build
some incredible campuses and
universities to compete against the
harvards and the yields and the
berkeleys and all this other stuff how
about we go do so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
[Music]